à dinard gurea nous commente à l'égout
remercie d'avoir accepté cette entrevue
pour éduquer
nationale mais ça m'a fait plaisir ça
fait grand plaisir
merci d'avoir accepté d'essayer ces
nouveaux moyens de communication et des
entrevues aussi merci donc que vous
travaillez à l'alliance des communautés
culturelles pour l'été dans les services
sociaux et de santé
et puis dernièrement cette alliance a
créé une série de brochures
d'information en 25 langues contenant
des informations sur les coronavirus et
la maladie qu'il provoque lakovic 19
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé pour
développer pour produire ses proches aux
informations en plusieurs langues ce qui
nous a motivés premièrement c'est notre
mission notre mission est vraiment comme
le nom le dit de l'égalité dans la santé
les services sociaux l'égalité d'accès
l'égalité aussi au niveau de
l'information reçue parce que l'égalité
veut aussi dire ça que toutes les
personnes et les informations requises
selon leurs capacités aussi de la
comprendre
donc pour nous laisser formations
multilingues sont une nécessité tant
donné étant donné la situation étant
donné qu'il ya des nouveaux arrivants
qui ne comprennent pas encore bien le
français ou l'anglais donc qu'ils
pouvaient se trouver perdu alors nous de
notre côté on a trouvé que c'était
essentiel de de produire ces documents
là je règle et ce n'est pas les gens
d'informations qu'on peut trouver sur le
site internet des bureaux de santé de
montréal ou encore du québec ou du
canada
non on fait tout ce qui est drôle c'est
que aussi le ministère de la santé des
services sociaux et aussi la direction
régionale de santé publique de montréal
pointe vers notre site pour les
documents multilingue puisque on a été
les premiers et il faut aussi dire que
nous à la fin du mois de janvier lorsque
l'on commencé à parler plus de
coronavirus notamment en chine
on a interpellé le gouvernement les
ministères de la santé des services
sociaux pour voir ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour avoir peut-être un mandat ou une
collaboration par rapport
justement à l'information multilingue et
ce qui est arrivé c'est que on a une
excuse et de réception vie finalement
nous a dit écoutez si on a besoin de
vous on va vous vous rappelez
et finalement quand on a vu qu'on avait
aucune réponse et que la situation
devenait de plus en plus préoccupante
avec des cas quand même dans plusieurs
pays occidentaux
un cas au québec appelez ça de après sa
6 après bourse a commencé à augmenter
nous on a décidé de produire le 11 ou le
12 des gens mars on a commencé à
produire le document le valider à
l'inter validé médicalement
selon les connaissances comme avait à ce
moment là et on a commencé tout de suite
les traductions donc déjà on a commencé
ce travail là qui a été vraiment ça fait
boule de neige
on l'a mis sur notre facebook on a mis
sur notre site dont beaucoup
d'intervenants beaucoup de personnes
étaient déjà au courant que nous
faisions ce travail et jusqu'aujourd'hui
les documents c'est que énormément bien
ce qu'on en fait quelques petites mises
à jour depuis
étant donné qu'il ya des renseignements
qui ont changé donc on a fait quelques
petites mises à jour mais ces documents
là son premier mois les premiers qui ont
été mutilés et deuxièmement beaucoup de
langues dans un court laps de temps la
maladie le gouvernement du québec cette
semaine
je crois que c'est le n 10 a développé
un certain série d'infographies à un
plusieurs langues gelé but parfait dans
le site web du ministère de la santé du
québec qui probablement encourage les
gens qui sont en contact avec des
nouveaux arrivants et des personnes
comme vous dites qu'ils ne parlent pas
la langue de les imprimer ou de les
distribuer en fait effectivement il y à
d'autres initiatives qui ont été un peu
plus tardif que la nôtre bon nous c'est
parce qu'on a à coeur cette mission là
qui est la nôtre
et puisqu'on n'a pas eu de réponse du
ministère de la santé oms n'a pas eu
vraiment un mandat clair c'était doux en
tant qu'organisme qu'on a ce mandat là
on pas le faire des gens vont se
demander
pourquoi il y à de nouveaux arrivants
qui comprennent pas le français ou
l'anglais étant donné que c'était une d1
des clippers finalement pour être
accepté comme résidents permanents en
premier puis finalement comme citoyen
canadien donc pourquoi ces personnes ne
pourraient pas assez informés dans les
deux langues lui l'angle du canada bien
sûr c'est une question légitime étant
donné que la connaissance linguistique
effectivement donc des points en plus
pour la résidence donc pour obtenir la
résidence canadienne et notamment aussi
québécoise si l'on veut donc la
connaissance du français lorsque c'est
une personne qui va s'établir au québec
la connaissance du français joue en sa
faveur
si elle l'a cependant il ne faut pas
oublier qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes
qui sont en attente du statut de
réfugiés dont qui demandent le statut de
réfugié ou qui sont fraîchement réfugiés
dont qui n'ont pas nécessairement une
connaissance linguistique suffisante
pour comprendre des informations
il y a aussi des personnes qui vivent
quand même assez isolés dans leur
communauté
étant donné aussi le fait qu'ils soient
réfugiés ou qui ne connaissent pas bien
le français l'anglais
il ya aussi les personnes parrainées
donc le la constitution de la famille
donc quelquefois la personne qui est ici
qui parraine son épaule son épouse
connaît la langue mais par la personne
qui vient donc il y à tous ces éléments
là et alors on parle vraiment de
population petit peu plus vulnérables
que ce qu'ils ont passés par le
processus d'immigration dont cabine à
hambourg et à un non vous n'êtes qu'un à
trizay l'observatoire famille
immigration à l'alliance des communautés
culturelles pour l'égalité dans la santé
et les services sociaux axés avec triple
s
merci boeing d'avoir accepté cette
entrevue et puis votre site va être sur
notre site internet mais si vous voulez
les mentionner rapidement sa dette ni
aussi bien oui notre site et triple w
un point access avec 3 parce que ce sont
des services sociaux - net
à noter donc dès que vous allez sur le
site vous allez voir bien sûr nos
dossiers mais le dossier principal
actuellement ses locaux vides 19 donc
vous allez voir la photo du virus puis
le les appellations plusieurs langues
vous savez nous avons créées pouvaient
avoir accès merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue et puis bonne chance pour la
suite et garder boen santé la merci
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup au revoir
au revoir bonjour n'est pas un terroir